hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
when we are considering the category of
relation as we find it in Chapter 7 of
Aristotle's work the categories there's
two things that he talks about that we
want to look at in a little bit more
detail particularly so that we can run
through the examples that he's using
let's remind ourselves to that when
we're talking about relative terms the
things that are the proeski in this
category of relation or the relative
we're talking about terms that are
understood in relation to another in in
relation to something else right so they
are either of another like for example
the Sun is the son of the father or the
mother likewise the mother is the mother
of the Sun or there understood in
relation to something else and
oftentimes these can be lexically you
know synonymous we can we can turn them
around so that we could say you know we
have this is essentially origin relation
or belonging relation or we can just
talk about relation itself now there's
two things that Aristotle talks about as
sometimes belonging to relative terms
and sometimes not and those are
contraries where terms are actually
contrary to each other or if you like
opposites is another way of putting it
or whether the terms admit of degrees so
let's look first at contrariness or
contrary the greek word here is an
auntie otays that's the substantive for
an auntie ah those those are the things
you know one thing is in an auntie on
and of the other things another Anansi
on plural and auntie up these are
opposed to each other and when we talk
about contrary usually what Aristotle
has in mind the examples that he
typically brings up throughout the rest
of this work are things like black and
white sweet salty actually sweet to
bitter when it comes to taste you know
when it comes to notes high and low
you know things along those lines hot
cold good bad now in this case he's
going to use virtue and vice and we'll
talk about that in just a minute so what
we want to point out is that not every
relative term or really pair of relative
terms court relatives admits of
contrariness they're not all opposites
to each other so for example he likes to
use this one quite a lot double one
thing is double of another that doesn't
mean that it's the things opposite right
and you could say well what about half
well that's a core relative but it's not
an opposite in the way that Aristotle is
talking about here likewise triple any
other sort of multiple word like that or
or a fraction word is just not going to
give us a relationship of contrariness
now we could contrast that to the one
that he actually brings up and this one
is a bit tricky as an example because he
talks about virtue or you know very
broadly speaking we could say goodness
right he says automating you know
excellent moral goodness and he says
this is contrary to vice kochia means
badness really at the core of it and why
is he bringing these up as relative term
especially since if you've read further
out in the work you know that he is
going to talk about these sorts of
things in terms of a different type of
category that of the one that's
following that of what do we call it the
quay on the quality right is a
particular kind of quality well virtues
and vices are what aristotle and greek
called Texas we translate that
as habits it's one of the Greek words
that we use to translate Hamilton so I
mean something that's really rooted in
your character in your typical response
to things you've developed it over time
but it's a virtue of something right the
virtue is itself relative to something
so if we talk about for one example
generosity or as it's often translated
liberality that's a virtue that bears
upon how you how you spend money how you
how you use your resources that you have
in relation to other people and in
relation to yourself right so it's a you
could say it's a virtue of spending and
receiving wealth as Aristotle does in
fact say in the nick of mackay and
ethics the vice would likewise be say it
will say the vices stin genus or my
Zerlina sore mean this sometimes it's
translated right that would also be a
vice of some particular subject matter
which is how we use our wealth in that
you know spending and receiving or as I
same getting and giving right and so
those are relatives they're not actually
relative to each other they're opposites
to each other so this can be a little
bit misleading right because it's not
that the virtue is the virtue of or
relational to vice and vice is
relational to virtue these are opposites
but these themselves are in fact
relative terms so this is a good example
of something that does in fact have a
set of opposite or contraries as
relative terms they're opposites in one
way their relative terms in another
likewise if we say knowledge and
ignorance and we say knowledge of I've
used the example of plumbing so let's
take carpentry as another example cuz
I'm a little bit tired of talking about
plumbing all the time so knowledge of
carpentry right you actually understand
how to
put together say something like a
chalkboard all right how to build this
this frame and then how to fit as might
be there might be so much I've how to
fit a slight piece inside of it now you
know a lot of people know how to do that
sort of thing they have the knowledge of
so there's the relation there how to
build a chalkboard carpentry and other
people have ignorance with respect to or
in relation to carpentry building a
chalkboard in this case right those
ignorance and knowledge would be
opposite or contraries to each other so
Aristotle can use those sorts of
examples as well so what we see is there
are some relations some relative terms
that do encompass opposites or
contraries but it's not that the
contrary themselves are in relation to
each other that's not where the relation
part is we might think about this in two
separate planes a little bit different
when we get to degrees now when we talk
in terms of degrees that's actually sort
of an English shorthand for the low
cution that Aristotle always uses for
this sort of thing which is a little bit
closer to the subject he talks about a
more and a less am alone and a hate jump
in his Greek right so why are we talking
about degree as well there's there's the
possibility of more there's the
possibility of less so take you know me
for example I'm a tall guy you can tell
by you know when I go up to the
chalkboard right chalkboard is I don't
know maybe six foot eight or something
like that I'm six foot three if I shrink
you know get smaller and smaller hey
does imagine imagine my bones shortening
hey then there's a left to me write my
height is becoming less and measured
against other objects or I could get
bigger and bigger and bigger right and
we can go on and on with with these
sorts of examples so what about that
when it comes to greater to Les Deux
relational terms admit of that Arizona
is like some don't have degrees and
notice that he uses the same example
this double right there's no such thing
as more or less double up something you
could say you're closer to double but
you're not you know if you've got the
word double on the table look it's
double its two times the thing you don't
get a more or less so this doesn't
doesn't actually work there are some
what we would call you know in some
respect quantitative terms although they
could also be quite qualitative where we
can talk about a greater and a less in
terms of relation notice that these
terms are relative terms that we we use
to talk about how things are connected
with each other so like home oil and
unlike auto my own these are actually to
some degree opposites aren't they the
way that they function here is that they
indicate a more or they admit of a more
and a less so we can say that two things
are more similar to each other more
alike to each other right pick another
guy who's roughly in its 40s wearing a
tie and a shirt maybe a different color
and i'm going to say he's a little bit
shorter than me and while we're
imagining what these satyr than me to
write because why not if he can do that
right and let's say he's balding and
i've got here well we're still similar
in many respects in that you know we're
both were both men we're both wearing
this thing now imagine that we you know
we've got identical ties and shirts and
that suddenly he sprouts the whole head
of hair and it's even you know tied and
back like this and maybe he wears
glasses too maybe he doesn't wear
glasses maybe we use the example that
comes up as like a TV trope right maybe
I'm the evil twin because I of course
have the goatee and
you know the glasses and so he's the
good guy you know an eightieth shows
right we're still very very similar to
each other and if we go further with
this example the more similar we are to
each other the better chance I'm going
to have as an evil twin in bringing
about my nefarious plan because I can
get people to think that hey it's just
you know we'll call them Craig instead
of Greg hey it's just Craig and he
happened to some croquet coats here that
is one of course took a little while to
girl but imagine it feel closer shaved
so hey it usually tends to be right so
those admit of degrees gets a little
tricky with the next example that
Aristotle uses equal and unequal here we
have to think out a little bit how is
this supposed to work for Aristotle
unequal on East Zone in Greek well that
one makes perfect sense we can say that
two things are more or less unequal to
each other the further apart that they
get right so you know again remember
imagining this this short fatter balding
version of myself that that's further
away from me not equal to me or you know
we could use that in other respects as
well equal gets a little bit tricky
because Aristotle has already associated
equality particularly with the category
of quantity so we have to think of
equality here as in terms of a relative
term how would that actually function
and it's not entirely clear so we have
to imagine something like thinking that
two things are very very similar to each
other and that's perhaps what he means
in this case x equal even though it's
translated is equal in this it's not
numerically quality but you know
something similar to similarity only
very very close proximity so now you
notice this is very interesting
some relational terms admit of contrary
some don't some admit of degrees and
some don't so you have to look at it on
a case-by-case basis